salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
aujourd'hui je ne suis pas seul je suis
avec une dame la dame de fer et c'est
une chance car elle ne devrait plus être
là aujourd'hui 20 ans après sa
construction elle devait être démontée
c'est grâce à un coup de génie de
Gustave Eiffel qu'elle est restée debout
alors comment a-t-il fait pour sauver
son chef-d'oeuvre je vous raconte tout
mais avant on va devoir prendre de la
hauteur
on va grimper tout là-haut
[Musique]
nous voilà arrivés au cinquième étage
alors j'ai beaucoup de chance car ce
niveau n'est pas accessible au public
d'ici la vue sur Paris est vraiment
imprenable
nous sommes perchés à 285 mètres de
hauteur le 31 mars 1889 Gustave Eiffel
gravit officiellement les marches de sa
tour pour la première fois du parvis au
sommet elle compte aujourd'hui
1665 marches mais à l'époque il y en
avait 2000 entouré de plusieurs
officiels il déploie alors le drapeau
français l'événement est salué par 21
coups de canon la Tour Eiffel fait la
Une des gazettes dans le monde entier
pour le génial entrepreneur c'est
l'aboutissement d'un projet hors norme
qui a germé dans son esprit cinq ans
auparavant en 1884 cette année-là la
France prépare l'Exposition universelle
de 1889 le pays veut en profiter pour
célébrer le centenaire de la Révolution
de 1789 mais encore faut-il trouver
quelque chose qui marque les esprits
nous sommes en pleine révolution
industrielle l'objectif des pouvoirs
publics est donc de faire rayonner le
génie industriel français en érigeant
une tour gigantesque sur le Champ de
Mars comme on aime déjà les chiffres
ronds on rêve d'une tour de 1000 pieds
300 mètres à cette époque Gustave Eiffel
s'est déjà fait un nom dans le domaine
des constructions métalliques avec deux
ouvrages révolutionnaires le pont de
Garabit dans le Midi et l'armature de la
Statue de la Liberté
du solide à surface égale le ferpudeler
qu'il utilise et dix fois plus résistant
que la pierre aussitôt ces ingénieurs se
mettent au travail de d'entre eux Émilie
Nouguier et Maurice Coquelin imagine un
gigantesque pylône métallique sur quatre
pieds exactement
300 mètres de hauteur ce premier croquis
n'est pas très élégant aussi Stephen
Sauvestre l'architecte attitré de
l'entreprise le redessine entièrement
cette fois le nouveau projet retravaillé
et décorer séduit Eiffel qui donne son
feu vert pour que les plans soient
présentés le concours est lancé en 1886
et quelques semaines plus tard sur la
centaine de projets en compétition c'est
le sien qui est retenu
[Musique]
ensuite tout va très vite la tour est
construite en un peu plus de deux ans
pour réaliser cet exploit toutes les
pièces sont prémontées dans les ateliers
Eiffel à Levallois-Perret en proche
banlieue 7300 tonnes de fer 18000 pièces
et 312 mètres plus haut et la dame de
fer est inaugurée en grande pompe elle
devient le monument le plus haut du
monde son succès est immédiat 2 millions
de personnes soit 12000 visiteurs par
jour ce reste au sommet pour découvrir
une vue inédite sur Paris pendant
l'Exposition Universelle alors Gustave
Eiffel devrait sauter de joie et bien
non car le contrat qu'il a signé avec la
Ville de Paris prévoit que la tour doit
être démontée au bout de 20 ans or lui
veut que sa tour reste debout et pour
convaincre la municipalité de son
utilité il a une idée en faire un
laboratoire scientifique avec sa taille
exceptionnelle c'est l'endroit idéal
l'idée à germer dans son esprit bien
avant le début des travaux observez la
frise qui court autour du premier étage
au moment de la construction et fait la
prise soin d'y faire inscrire les noms
de 72 savants en lettres capitales et
figure le chimiste de Lavoisier Daguerre
l'inventeur de la photographie ou encore
le médecin Xavier Bichat pour être plus
près des travaux qui vont s'y dérouler
l'entrepreneur doit installer ses
bureaux sur place il se fait donc
construire un petit appartement ici au
quatrième étage on va aller y faire un
tour
[Musique]
bonjour messieurs dames c'est pas très
grand à l'époque c'était beaucoup plus
spacieux il n'y avait pas autant de
locaux techniques il y avait des canapés
pour accueillir les visiteurs un lavabo
et même des toilettes cet appareil un
phonographe est également d'origine la
scène représente Gustave Eiffel sa fille
Claire et Thomas Edison venu justement
en personne présentée ce fameux
phonographe à l'Exposition universelle
de 1889 alors Gustave Eiffel il passe
des heures à étudier les moyens qui
pourraient sauver sa tête il commence à
faire installer un pendule de Foucault
sous le deuxième étage les oscillations
amplifiées vont mettre en évidence la
rotation de la Terre mais il le sait ça
ne suffira pas à convaincre les
autorités cette expérience a déjà été
réalisée au Panthéon quelques années
auparavant il mise plutôt sur une
science encore balbutiante la
météorologie à 300 mètres d'altitude le
vent la température
l'hygrométrie c'est-à-dire le taux
d'humidité dans l'air ne sont pas les
mêmes consoles ces mesures sont
cruciales pour comprendre le temps qu'il
fait et réaliser des prévisions avec
l'aide du physicien et le terme mascar
effet l'installe au cinquième étage une
station météo unique au monde les
instruments sont disposés sur une petite
plateforme et toutes les heures il
mesure la température de l'air la
vitesse du vent la pression
l'hygrométrie les données sont aussi au
transmises par câble un des appareils
enregistreurs situés au sol résultat
sont ensuite publiés au frais de Gustave
Eiffel lui-même finalement c'est grâce à
cette station que l'on connaît avec
précision le temps qu'il fait à Paris
depuis la fin du 19e siècle évidemment
depuis les appareils ont beaucoup évolué
merci Monsieur dame
ça souffle
à cette altitude il y a toujours du vent
un phénomène auquel Gustave Eiffel
s'intéresse tout particulièrement
surtout depuis qu'en 1884 un viaduc
s'est effondré à cause d'une tempête
pour mesurer ses effets sur les
structures il fait installer un
dispositif astucieux au deuxième étage
pour mesurer la pression que le vent
exerce sur les objets je vous explique
mais avant on descend
[Musique]
à l'ouverture en 1889 les visiteurs
peuvent déjà monter et descendre grâce à
5 ascenseurs parmi lesquels trois sont
hydrauliques aujourd'hui deux
fonctionnent encore
Eiffel fait pendre un câble de 115
mètres entre ce deuxième étage et le
plancher des vaches il avait baptisé ce
dispositif l'appareil de chute sur ce
câble les scientifiques font glisser des
objets de taille et de forme différente
un système de mesure fixé aux objets
eux-mêmes permettaient d'évaluer la
résistance de l'air au corps en chute
libre et inversement la pression que
l'air en mouvement exerce sur les corps
immobile plus tard Eiffel complète ses
expériences sur l'air et le vent en
installant un laboratoire
d'aérodynamique il se trouvait au pied
de la tour avant d'être déplacé dans le
16e arrondissement en 1912
[Musique]
finalement c'est une autre invention
révolutionnaire qui va sauver la dame de
fer la télégraphie sans fil c'est une
technique qui utilise les ondes
électromagnétiques pour transmettre des
messages en alphabet morts le 5 novembre
1898 Gustave Eiffel autorise
l'industriel Eugène ducreté a réalisé
depuis la tour la toute première
transmission sans fil française le 1er
message est envoyé au Panthéon qui se
trouve à 4 km les ondes
électromagnétiques parcourent cette
distance sans rencontrer le moindre
obstacle le principe de la radio est née
la post émetteur est alors installé à
demeure il permet en 1899 d'établir une
liaison avec l'ombre peu après en 1903
le capitaine Gustave Ferrier qui est
chargée par l'armée d'étudier les
applications militaires de la TSF saute
sur l'occasion et propose d'y installer
ses antennes au 5e étage grâce à ses
antennes radio Latour joue désormais un
rôle stratégique de premier plan pour le
pays elle devient incontournable je
dirais même plus elle devient un des
boulonnable
et le premier mai 1910 la ville de Paris
renouvelle sa concession pour 70 ans
Gustave Eiffel a gagné son pari
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et l'histoire ne s'arrête pas là à la
même époque la radio commence à pénétrer
dans les foyers et le 22 décembre 1921
c'est la naissance de radio Tour Eiffel
qui remporte un immense succès la
station émettra pendant 19 ans jusqu'à
l'occupation allemande en juin 1940 plus
tard la dame de fer deviendra le berceau
de la télévision française le tout
premier émetteur est installé au sommet
en 1935 mais ça Gustave Eiffel ne le
verra pas il s'éteint le 27 décembre
1923 aujourd'hui grâce à toutes ces
antennes elle a grandi en mars 2022 elle
a atteint
339 alors la Tour Eiffel n'est plus le
plus haut bâtiment de la planète mais
son seul nom évoque le prestige de notre
capital dans le monde entier c'était
donc pas par hasard si chaque année plus
de 6 millions de personnes les quatre
coins du monde viennent la visiter la
tour de Gustave Eiffel est désormais
l'un des monuments payants et les plus
visités au monde
[Musique]
et voilà fin de la visite alors si cette
balade épicurieuse sur la Tour Eiffel
vous a plu je vous conseille vivement de
venir la découvrir ou la redécouvrir par
vous-même les plus sportifs pourront
même gravir les marches qui mènent au
deuxième étage vous verrez c'est une
expérience inoubliable pour les yeux et
pour les mollets allez excellente
semaine à toutes et à tous et à dimanche
prochain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]